dn store ara
at the present era at all from noble
prince tyranny literature Bob Dylan
tallit from fish Oden abrecan's gamba
Sodor and Aishwarya
azita Raji it is a great honor to
introduce a speech from the Nobel
laureate in literature mr. Bob Dylan the
speech is presented by the ambassador of
the United States of America to Sweden
Her Excellency azita Raji
[Applause]
thank you thank you it's a pleasure to
be with you tonight for me and to read
mr. Bob Dylan's speech in recognition of
the honor he has been awarded by the
Nobel Committee here it is good evening
everyone I extend my warmest greetings
to the members of the Swedish Academy
and to all of the other distinguished
guests in attendance tonight I'm sorry I
can't be with you in person but please
know that I'm most definitely with you
in spirit and honored to be receiving
such a prestigious prize being awarded
the Nobel Prize for Literature is
something I never could have imagined or
seen coming from an early age I've been
familiar with and reading and absorbing
the works of those who were deemed
worthy of such a distinction Kipling
Shaw Thomas Mann Pearl Buck Albert Camus
Hemingway these giants of literature
whose works are taught in the classroom
housed in libraries around the world and
spoken of in reverent tones have always
made a deep impression that I now join
the names on such a list is truly beyond
words
I don't know if these men and women ever
thought of the Nobel Honor for
themselves but I suppose that anyone
writing a book or a poem or a play
anywhere in the world might Harbor that
secret dream deep down inside it's
probably buried so deep that they don't
even know it's there
if someone had ever told me that
had the slightest chance of winning the
Nobel Prize I would have to think that
I'd have about the same odds as standing
on the moon in fact during the year I
was born and for a few years late after
there wasn't anyone in the world who was
considered good enough to win this Nobel
Prize so I recognize that I'm in very
rare company to say the least I was out
on the road when I received the
surprising news and it took me more than
a few minutes to properly process it I
began to think about William Shakespeare
the great literary figure I would reckon
he thought of himself as a dramatist the
thought that he was writing literature
couldn't have entered his head his words
were written for the stage meant to be
spoken not read when he was writing
Hamlet I'm sure he was thinking about a
lot of different things who were the
right actors for these roles how should
this be staged do I really want to set
this in Denmark
his creative vision and ambitions were
no doubt at the forefront of his mind
but there were also more mundane matters
to consider and deal with is the
financing in place are there enough good
seats for my patrons where am I going to
get a human skull I would bet that the
farthest thing from Shakespeare's mind
was the question is this literature when
I started writing songs as a teenager
and even as I started to achieve some
renown for my abilities my aspirations
for these songs only went so far I
thought they could be heard in coffee
houses or bars maybe later in places
like Carnegie Hall the London Palladium
if I was really dreaming big maybe I
could imagine getting to make a record
and then hearing my songs on the radio
that was really the big prize in my mind
making records and hearing your songs on
the radio
meant that you were reaching a big
audience and that you might get to keep
doing what you had set out to do well I
have been doing what I set out to do for
a long time now I've made dozens of
Records and played thousands of concerts
all around the world but it's my songs
that are at the vital center of almost
everything I do they seem to have found
a place in the lives of many people
throughout many different cultures and
I'm grateful for that
but there's one thing I must say as a
performer
I've played for 50,000 people and I've
played for 50 people
and I can tell you that it is harder to
play for fifty people fifty thousand
people have a singular persona not so
with fifty each person has an individual
separate identity a world onto
themselves they can perceive things more
clearly your honesty and how it relates
to the depth of your talent is tried the
fact that the Nobel Committee is so
small is not lost on me
but like Shakespeare
I too am often occupied with the pursuit
of my creative endeavors and dealing
with all aspects of life's mundane
matters who are the best musicians for
these songs am i recording in the right
studio is this song in the right key
some things never change
even in 400 years not once have I ever
had the time to ask myself are my songs
literature so I do thank the Swedish
Academy both for taking the time to
consider that very question and
ultimately for providing such a
wonderful answer my very best wishes to
you all Bob Dylan
[Applause]